mieux vaut une banane ou pour chaque chef est
apparenté
rester avec moi est le patient qui doit
trouver du réconfort dans le lit numéro le médecin
était-il assis avec lui je parie que ce
serait le moment le plus heureux de ma vie
Emma tu nous as rejoint à  enfin c'est le
dernier romantique de toute la France je
ne pense qu'à toi je suis marié
madame bovary comme tout le monde a dit tu ne dois
vraiment pas te soucier du crédit
cher docteur
le devoir est de se sentir prescrit
chéri n'acceptez pas les conventions
de la société
à chaque instant vous ne possédez pas ce que vous
aimez est un instant non passé en amour
votre dette est devenue assez colossale
vous devez commencer aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas fait pour être
qui était ça  l'huissier tu m'as fait
croire que tu m'aimais tu
pensais que ce serait un espion et un
démystificateur jusqu'à la fin des temps tu es un
rat
Non